[Música]
nuestros recuerdos nos representan nos
ayuda a recordar nuestro pasado a
aprender y retener habilidades y a
planificar el futuro y para la
computadora que actúa como una extensión
de nosotros mismos la memoria juega el
mismo papel se trata de una película de
dos horas un archivo de texto de dos
palabras o las instrucciones para
ponerla en marcha y toda su memoria
tiene como unidades básicas las
denominadas bits o dígitos binarios
cada uno de estos se almacena en una
celda de memoria cuyo estado puede
variar entre dos valores posibles 0 y 1
los archivos y los programas contienen
millones de estos bits que están
procesados dentro de la unidad de
procesamiento central o cpu que actúa
como el cerebro de la computadora y
conforme crece exponencialmente la
cantidad de bits que procesan los
diseñadores de computadoras intentan
constantemente solucionar el problema
del tamaño costo y velocidad
las computadoras tienen memoria a corto
plazo para las tareas inmediatas y a
largo plazo para el almacenamiento
permanente al ejecutar un programa su
sistema operativo asigna un área dentro
de la memoria a corto plazo para esas
instrucciones por ejemplo al pulsar una
tecla en un procesador de texto la cpu
accederá a uno de estos lugares para
recuperar los bits de datos también
podría modificarlos o crear otros nuevos
el tiempo necesario para hacerlo es la
latencia de la memoria
y debido a que las instrucciones de cada
programa deben ser procesadas rápida y
continuamente se puede acceder a
cualquier espacio dentro de la memoria a
corto plazo en cualquier orden y de ahí
el nombre de memoria de acceso aleatorio
o Ram el tipo más común de memoria RAM
es memoria RAM dinámica o de ram allí
cada celda consta de un pequeño
transistor y un condensador que
almacenan cargas eléctricas representada
con un cero cuando no está cargada o un
uno cuando lo está
dicha memoria se llama dinámica porque
mantiene una carga brevemente antes de
perderla y necesita recargarse
periódicamente para retener datos pero
incluso su baja latencia de unos 100
nanosegundos es demasiado para la cpu
modernas Así que también hay un pequeño
caché de memoria interna de alta
velocidad compuesta por Ram estática
esto significa seis transistores
entrelazados que no necesitan recarga la
sram es la memoria más rápida dentro de
un sistema operativo pero también la más
cara y ocupa tres veces más espacio que
la de ram pero la memoria RAM y el caché
pueden almacenar datos si reciben
alimentación para que los datos No se
pierdan cuando se apaga el dispositivo
hay que transferirlos a uno de largo
plazo Existen tres tipos principales en
un almacenamiento magnético los datos se
almacenan según un patrón magnético en
un disco giratorio cubierto con una
película magnética pero debido a que el
disco debe girar para encontrar Dónde
están los datos para poder leerlos la
latencia de estas unidades es 100.000
veces más lentas que la de una de ram
el almacenamiento óptico como el DVD y
blu-ray también usa discos giratorios
pero con un revestimiento reflectante
los bits se codifican como puntos de luz
u oscuros con un colorante que puede ser
leído por un láser mientras que los
medios de almacenamiento ópticos son
baratos y desmontables su latencia
supera la del almacenamiento magnético y
tienen menor capacidad
los tipos más nuevos y más rápidos de
almacenamiento a largo plazo son las
unidades de estado sólido como la
memoria flash estos no tienen partes
móviles y usan transistores de puerta
flotante que almacenan datos al atrapar
o eliminar cargas eléctricas dentro de
sus estructuras internas especialmente
diseñadas
entonces son fiables estos millones de
bits creemos que la memoria de una
computadora es estable y permanente pero
se degrada con rapidez el calor generado
por sus dispositivos y su entorno
desmagnetiza los discos duros degrada el
colorante de los soportes ópticos y
causa fugas de carga en puertas
flotantes en las unidades de estado
sólido el uso repetido de los
transistores de puerta flotante las
corroe hasta dejarlas inservibles a
partir de los datos sobre los medios de
almacenamiento actuales y con una
esperanza de vida de menos de 10 años
los científicos intentan explotar las
propiedades físicas de los materiales
con la esperanza de hacer estos
dispositivos de memoria más rápidos
pequeños y duraderos por ahora la
inmortalidad es lejana tanto para los
seres humanos como para las computadoras
las computadoras Ejecutan algoritmos
constantemente pero los humanos también
pueden usar algoritmos para resolver
problemas y ordenar información descubra
con este video Cómo usar los principios
de las ciencias informáticas para
organizar su biblioteca